I get this question all the time.
I literally saw a woman in Costco waiting for her hot dog
and I was like,
where did you get that sweater?
It looks so snuggly and amazing.
And it is. Here's the thing I bought.
That woman told me the same thing when I asked her.
It's from a tiny Little Fucking Farm store in the west called Murdochs.
M U R D O C H S Murdochs.
And the name of the sweater brand is Wanna Comi?
They're in Canada.
It's really fucking.
I don't. My boyfriend got me this sweater
because the little farm store website is always down.
They're always having a problem with shipping.
It's just a really shitty website.
So, like, when it's working, you can order the sweater just fine.
There's also a hooded version that I want.
This brand, the Canadian brand,
they also have like a shitty website and you can like.
It doesn't ship to everywhere.
So that is
all the information on this sweater that people always ask me about.
It is as comfortable and snuggly as you want.
It does get a little chokey though.
Also, it.
The only thing that sucks about it is you can only wear it like that.
Like, you can't.
It's kind of.
I don't know. You know what I mean?
Like, when it's not all snuggled up,
it's kind of not the most easy to wear,
but it is snuggly,
so hope that helps.